ah ah ah ah
ó
[Música]
essa pirâmide
mudou minha vida eu era médico
eu era se fale atrás se fale atleta é um
especialista em dor de cabeça que na
prática uma mistura de neurologistas
psiquiatras e nessa época eu já tinha me
tornado palestrante julgava um
palestrante
até que me apresentou essa pirâmide se
veja que quando você assistir uma
palestra
você guarda 5% do que foi dito quando
você dá uma palestra
você guarda 80% do que você fala ea
provocação que ele fez foi você gostaria
de continuar a ser um showman um
palestrante o você quer ser de fato um
educador e eu acredito que sim
a educação é transformadora mas antes de
chegar nesse dia nessa pirâmide nessa
transformação como é que tudo isso
aconteceu durante a minha faculdade eu
tive que dá aula em vários cenários para
poder me manter
mal sabia que é onde eu estava dando
aula já estava sendo a minha verdadeira
escola bom
formei me especializei adentrei nessa
área e comecei a ser convidado por
algumas empresas para dar palestras
sobre o assunto que me especializei um
dia numa cidade muito distante
depois de uma palestra a gente saiu para
jantar e um participante me fez uma
pergunta que eu pensei 'esse ou ele não
estava na aula
ele estava dormindo porque eu falei só
30 minutos atrás
é possível que ele não entendeu eu
comecei a perceber que nas palestras
duas três pessoas interagiram entendiam
as demais ouviam mas não aprendiam bom
não era eu o único que estava percebendo
isso as empresas começaram utilizar
discussões em pequenos grupos
utilizando esse paradigma da curva de
adoção para misturar pessoas que adotam
uma inovação muito precocemente
com a grande maioria isso é chamado ou
era chamado nas empresas de pia to pia
permite que as pessoas interagirem
internamente as pessoas chamavam esses
encontros de birth to be a porque a
única coisa que eles não faziam era
conversar com o assunto tratado nessa
época eu dava aula numa faculdade que
abandonou as aulas tradicionais e usava
um método de ensino chamado pbl prova 10
elaine na prática uma discussão de
problemas para promover o aprendizado e
aí eu pensei esse outro sucesso os
princípios do probem islane misturar se
esses perfis e permitisse que um
aprendesse com o outro
ao criar essas conexões surgiu um método
chamado synapse beiser lane ou sbl deixa
mostrar pra vocês como isso aconteceu
[Música]
quando você pensa em aprendizado
provavelmente você pensa numa cena como
essa certo mas ela definitivamente não é
a melhor forma para se aprender a 1
em palestras tradicionais a taxa média
de retenção de conhecimento é de apenas
5% para a audiência e de 80% para o
palestrante
então quem é que aprendi de verdade numa
aula expositiva outras ferramentas de
ensino aumentam consideravelmente esse
aprendizado
as discussões de grupo em especial
quando bem estruturadas e levam essa
taxa de retenção para em torno de 50%
por isso foi criado um método sbl
sinapse desde lane um híbrido de aula
expositiva e o grupo tutorial do próprio
andrés lane bbl o método é uma discussão
de uma situação problema em pequenos
grupos com oito a 16 participantes com
uma hora e meia de duração a discussão
promove a interação entre os
participantes com diferentes perfis
conforme a curva de adoção de inovação
vejamos como são esses perfis
entusiastas considerados aventureiros
sempre dispostos a abraçar tudo que é
novidade
[Música]
líderes de opinião fundamentais como
influenciadores em geral são tidos como
referência de vanguarda no mercado
pragmáticos nem os primeiros nem os
últimos sabe como é
tendem a ponderar mais sobre suas
decisões conservadores muito cautelosos
mais desconfiados
céticos muito resistentes super
conservadores nas suas preferências
a idéia é promover a interação entre
pares numa forma de aprendizagem
interpessoal
para isso a gente compõe a mesa assim a
discussão é liderada por um moderador
pré treinando o professor tradicional se
torna um convidado especial chamado
gabarito e como convidados chamamos um
ou dois entusiastas pelo menos dois
líderes de opinião um assunto discutido
6 a 8 pragmáticos 4 a 6 conservadores e
os céticos
bom vamos deixá los de fora deste método
e como funciona a discussão o moderador
um slide kit como roteiro antes do
debate em si ele faz a ativação de
conhecimentos prévios com a exposição de
dados que contextualizam o problema
na seqüência apresenta o problema e
promove a interação sobre diagnóstico
diferencial e tratamento baseado em
evidência confrontando as vivências
após a discussão a solução é apresentada
também no formato positivo a
implementação da metodologia passa por
várias etapas da definição dos objetivos
de aprendizagem passando pela elaboração
da situação problema
o desenvolvimento do slide kit a seleção
dos moderadores a capacitação dos
moderadores em uma oficina de
treinamento até a realização dos
encontros
vejam que na prática é uma discussão com
bastante diversidade
a mesa é composta pelo que eles perfis o
professor tradicional vir um gabarito eo
moderador que foi pré treinando algumas
técnicas lidera a discussão para chegar
nesse modelo
eu tive que mergulhar para entender como
ser humano pensa frente a problemas as
situações complexas e se a gente foi
entender como o ser humano decide no
xadrez da para exportar isso pra como
cirurgião pensa como a bailarina pensa
como um atleta de alta performance
na verdade em situações complexas os
ex-peões os especialistas não vêem esse
tabuleiro como um jogador qualquer
eles vêm está buller de uma maneira
diferente e vejam que interessante a
partir da quinta sexta jogada do xadrez
você tem bilhões de possibilidades em
cada jogada e o computador
claro tem uma capacidade de avaliar
muito mais jogadas
só que até a criação desse computador de
blu o computador não era capaz de ganhar
do ser humano porque porque o expert o
especialista têm um script que ele
decide automaticamente ele decide pela
intuição ele vê várias situações e
elimina inúmeras depois que o the blue
foi criado o computador passou a imitar
o jeito dos mestres de enxadristas
jogarem
nunca mais a gente ganhou do computador
ea evolução da inteligência artificial
mostra que os especialistas pensam
diferente
será que é possível pegar esse jeito de
pensar o especialista e compartilhar
para várias pessoas
é importante entender que sim o nosso
cérebro usa dois sistemas de decisão um
automático emocional que calcula quanto
é um mais um é que permite dirigir uma
estrada que você já conhece mas quando
você está numa estrada sinuosa que você
não conhece ou quando você precisa fazer
essa conta
você usa o sistema 2 a idéia é se o
promover
reflexão ativar o sistema 2 eu posso
construir novos escritos como dos apps
para várias pessoas
mas como fazer isso como acelerar esse
processo entendendo um conceito muito
importante que a influência social que é
como as pessoas influenciam mas as
outras existe um cenário onde uma
maioria convence uma minoria quando o
convencimento acontece a gente chama
isso de conformidade e o oposto também
acontece quando uma minoria convence uma
maioria
vamos ver primeiro o exemplo de maioria
com melhoria e acha que está mesmo na
sacola disse saunders a nossa cópia
princesa interessante é bom não tinha
estudo a gente tem aqui em vez de outro
sexo em tese contractors adicione praça
em abril um teste de atibá grupo funk
vai lá vai
o land romanos a dança estilo
[Música]
wine wine
to one bons e gum acredita tanto é este
ano entrei e saí
frei trair e acha que permite o primeiro
piso do mag shopping em campinas
we were so da google descobriu que o
grupo e lê
op por sem colete
esse foi um exemplo de maioria para a
melhoria e o contrário será que uma
minoria é capaz de convencer uma maioria
quando você está diante de um problema
de resultado incerto de um problema
julgamento tal que não existe resposta
exata
se a maioria perceber que existe uma
melhoria consistente e segura ela
aumenta sua taxa de conformidade
então essa idéia da metodologia trazer
um expert para compartilhar o seu modelo
de pensamento com os demais e ajudar o
grupo a desenvolver sua expertise a
gente fez um cenário muito interessante
com pequenos cafeicultores familiares
esses cafeicultores eles vêm de várias
gerações
na atividade ele sabe muito sobre
produzir café mas eles são muito
teimosos pra adquirir novas práticas
uma delas é obter selos de
sustentabilidade que permita colocar
esse produto em mercados internacionais
eles acham que esse selo dá muito
trabalho tem que preencher muito papel
incluir incluindo anotar os custos e não
vale a pena o pequeno prémio que a
sustentabilidade paga o que eles não
percebem é que a sustentabilidade além
de respeitar o social às pessoas e
ambiental é uma forma de gestão é uma
forma de eles saberem os seus próprios
custos e quando o preço do café cai
essas pessoas ficam muito à mercê disso
o que a gente fez é que nós temos uma
mulher como influenciadora para a
questão social
ao para a questão de cuidado com a
questão de detalhe
um produtor rural que já tinha
trabalhado com contabilidade e que sabe
como anotar cursos é importante e nós
fizemos um grupo onde eu fui o moderador
e um engenheiro agrônomo especialista em
café foi o gabarito e se essa dinâmica
promoveu uma taxa de conformidade de 60%
sessenta por cento dos participantes
perceberam que se obtivesse
sustentabilidade eu posso manter a
próxima geração fixa na atividade e é
isso que a gente faz é isso que o método
promove para isso acontecer tem um
detalhe diversidade é muito interessante
só que ela depende de alguém que
facilite a comunicação porque senão as
pessoas não interagem com a máxima
performance pra isso na nossa
metodologia o moderador é treinado e 6
técnicas que em suma são escuta ativa
escuta atenta escutatória além disso
perguntas abertas que promovem a
reflexão para a frase ao que está sendo
dito pela discussão tem uma conexão
cadenciado discussão como maestro para
que todos possam participar
sistematizar o que foi dito para não
ficar confuso e finalmente legitimar a
quem sabe muito do assunto essas pessoas
quando são estimadas elas relaxam na
discussão e uma coisa muito interessante
lembrar do exemplo que eu contei da
pessoa que foi na palestra no jantar não
sabia do que se tratava e eu percebi que
essas pessoas não tinham voz
essas pessoas não eram ouvidas só os
professores muito ex pears é que podiam
falar na nossa metodologia todos têm que
participar o moderadora treinando há em
poder ao indivíduo a dar pra ele voz
isso aumenta a taxa de conformidade
por fim a gente percebe que o desfecho
final dessa história é de planície e
aprendizagem profunda quando uma criança
estuda passar na prova isso aprendizagem
especial quando uma criança estuda
porque está curiosa não esquece mais
curiosidade é fundamental
tecnicamente a gente chama de motivação
intrínseca
segundo essa sensação que eu faço parte
abre para eu participar terceiro eu
tenho que ativar conhecimentos prévios
para ensinar algo novo o cérebro faz uma
rede semântica uma rede sinapses que
conecta o novo com que eu já sabia e
finalmente o mais interessante você pode
promover de pilar ning trazendo mais
informações só que na prática o jeito
mais fácil é as informações já estão aí
se você criar as conexões principalmente
diárias que parecem distintas e as
pessoas vêem de forma fragmentada você
promove de planing a inteligência
artificial está se movendo para isso
esse cérebro é o nosso órgão é capaz de
fazer isso hoje eu olho para trás e
pergunto valeu a pena largar medicina
às vezes eu recebo ligações de pessoas
que eu tratava e me dizem assim doutorar
e isso não está atendendo mais um brinca
sou um médico tão legal foi tão bom pra
mim claro que isso dói eu penso na minha
trajetória vem de família simples foi
muito difícil me formar
mas hoje nós já treinamos essa
metodologia mais de 2.500 profissionais
entre médicos farmacêuticos engenheiro
agrônomos dentistas e essas pessoas a
replicar uma metodologia para milhares
de outros profissionais
hoje eu vivo de fazer train the trainer
e isso eu percebo que atinge milhares de
pessoas
então eu sinto que aquela pirâmide fez
conexão realmente eu me transformei em
educador e almir transformar educador
eu encontrei uma forma de transformar o
mundo
obrigado
[Aplausos]